Hello everybody!
Hi, hi, hi, I was getting jikki with it and I couldn't stop.
Why is it such a vibe?
Welcome to Nabi's Number Factory!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
I don't know anything about this game.
I don't even remember how I found it.
I think I was looking for...
I don't remember how I found it.
Who up nubbing their numbers?
Nubby.
We're making numbers, though.
We're making numbers now.
Was it Nimi?
Mm-mm.
No.
I found it on Steam and I was just like, This kind of looks like, uh...
What's the word?
Peggle.
And I was like, I wonder if it's like a peggle.
Nimmy or Northern Lion?
Nope.
No, I found it on my own, okay?
Yeah, I thought it looked like peggle.
So I chose it.
But I'm excited.
I've never watched Northern Lion before.
I know Nimmy really likes him, but...
all I know is that that guy is bald I don't know anything else about it
I don't know anything about it
can we get a ball wait should I pretend to be him today but I don't know anything about him does he have a catchphrase wait hold on I know one We're going north!
Because we're lying it up!
Head north, fellas!
Head north!
Any tips on how to get a cute ghost to haunt somebody asking for a friend?
Uh, you could summon them through the Ouija board?
What do you mean, minus two?
It's just like him.
And he has glasses on also.
And when you summon it goes through the Ouija board.
You have to say...
I offer my body and soul to you.
Please possess me and use my vessel for however you wish.
And also help yourself to...
the cheez-its in the pantry.
That's what you have to say, and then the ghost will stay forever.
But you gotta get like the extra toasted cheez-its.
Agreed?
Okay, I'm done being bald now.
You gotta get the extra toasted cheez-its.
Toast stare directly into the camera and say the most deranged hot take off the cuff you think you can just casually say on stream be bald and be a person who visited asia before okay i can be bald i've visited asia what's a hot take i'm
new hi new welcome back thank you
thoughts on japanese restaurants
why is this harder than i thought it was
I'm done being bald and polio were so simple for us.
Why is this hard?
Hold on.
The bit is over.
No, it's not!
The bit is alive!
Japanese restaurants.
You can take me hot to go, Minto.
H-O-T-T-O-T-O.
Why is this so hard?
I can't even make up something.
That like, that like, I...
Like that I don't believe.
But it's just a hot take.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Japanese restaurants.
They need more...
I need...
Less fish!
I was so bold.
Only- only I would come up with something so controversial.
I'm not even like- I'm not even like, oh I gotta be careful because I don't want people to clip this out of context and cancel me.
Like I literally can't think of anything.
Love the new dude.
Oh, thank you!
This is so bald of me.
Needs to be dumber.
We have Japanese restaurants.
Just need to stop being Japanese.
I think they should instead only be hibachi grills.
And if I don't get my choo-choo train onion stack, I think the place is lame.
you guys know what i'm talking about they make like the onion stack and they'll make it into a volcano or something and then they'll be like okay it's a choo-choo train now and they're like they like push it and says it's a choo-choo train let's fish more hot dog i think all restaurants that are not claiming to be american style should also serve burgers and fries no matter what kind of restaurant it is i think that's just uh you know
there's no other there's no other meal that should be served every restaurant no matter what kind It is.
It could even be an ice cream parlor.
Meets to serve a burger and fries.
Okay, I'm done being bald for real.
I got one for you.
Japanese restaurants need to give you three chopsticks just in case.
Guess what?
You can get burgers and fries and dairy coins.
I think I've only been to Dairy Queen like one time ever They could just mash the sushi into a burger patty and fry it on the grill
Get my Michelin star chef who came from Japan From the top world renowned sushi restaurant And he moved to the States To the US of A and he's having to smush together all the fish to make a splendid sushi burger patty and then fry it on the grill wait no not fry grill it up on the grill sashimi no more i'm
at the dmv trying to renew my licenses and order a burger and fries combo actually every establishment should be able to serve a fry and burger set more like Gnashi, man.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
You go to the post office?
I'm here to mail my package and get me a double patty.
He had a sushi place, triple wielding chopsticks, like Zoro for one piece.
Burgers at the funeral home?
If I...
If I knew, I would have...
I should have been able to...
Arrange my own funeral.
I would have allowed it.
Did you steal my wallet?
I can't find it.
No?
Oh my gosh, would you guys come to my...
Wait, I don't know if I ever got a funeral.
Can I plan one and you guys come to it?
Can I get a sashimi American style?
Yeah, yeah, you would.
You would go.
You would pay your respects.
You would?
Can we bring cake?
I'm not...
No.
You're not allowed to eat at my funeral because I can't eat.
I can't eat.
I'm dead.
Well, I would be dead in the casket.
It would be an open casket.
But don't worry.
My body is like long skeletonized.
So it's probably just a mannequin.
Or...
someone can offer to you could either die you could either dress up as me and die or you could stay alive and just you can't move for like seven hours
will it be open bar only tomato juice meinto morn and greet what if we cremate the cake I've actually been thinking about how to do this I was like maybe I can I want to have like a...
I was like, I kind of want to set up like a meet-and-greet, but as a funeral.
We'll put you on a TV screen and put the TV screen in the coffin as the meet-and-greet.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've been like kind of playing with the idea for real.
Can I do the ending monologue from the end of MGS2?
What does that have to do with me, huh?
Weirdest pitch for the new cosplay sets.
Where there'll be finger sandwiches.
No.
Putting the fun in funeral.
Revolving sushi in funeral.
Danny, the cosplayer.
She's so cute.
Just put the numbers in the factory, mate.
Yeah, we should play the game.
Sorry, I'm just yapping.
I don't know anything about this game, so I'm excited.
to help me out.
Excited for you to help me out.
Also, I've been drinking an energy...
I was so tired.
So I got an energy...
It's not a drink.
It's...
It was like...
Not a smoothie.
That's the thing.
Not a shot.
No.
Not an enema, no.
Like a...
Not a milkshake.
Burgers and fries at the funeral?
Put the fries in the bang.
Like, why?
Like a slushy!
A slushy!
That's the word.
A energy slushy.
I had Dutch bros for the first time the other day, you guys.
I think I get the hype I didn't have any coffee
but I had one of their I had like a one of their things from the holiday menu and it was so good but but okay anyway let's play the game oh hey you must be the new employee they were telling me about my name is tony and i'm gonna be your supervisor all the whispers crying at the funeral and then cosplayer we got to play as mince or snoring in the casket easiest job ever for that person because they could just sleep the whole time my job is to show you how to run the factory oh my god holy kingdom hearts cutscene i don't really care about your name or anything so let's to get to it.
Get into it.
Oh, he's really happy.
First things first, welcome aboard to Nubby's number factory.
The world's leading number manufacturer.
This is the main control center of the factory.
Your first task is to launch our mascot Nubby down the pegboard.
Hold down right mouse and press left mouse to launch Nubby.
I'm sending him in So I can't speak.
Oh, I forgot to press left.
Oh, he doesn't bounce.
Well, you're really good at this.
At this factory, your only job is to make big numbers.
I'm a cinnamon.
I'm a cinnamon down.
I like his glasses.
What about mine?
You like my glasses?
and you like my glasses
sorry but they're crooked
were you waiting to do that yeah i paid that chatter to send that message so that i could do them
Yeah, I was just like, okay, at 7.21 p.m.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
By launching Nubby at these pegs, you will earn however many points are shown on the peg.
That's what Northern Lion would say.
You can keep yapping.
Oh, yay!
This number shows how many points you have.
You made it in a round.
The number on the bottom is the goal.
If you beat the goal, the board will restock.
If you get really high score, the board can restock multiple times in a single round.
Oh, what?
I forgot to tell you what a restock even is!
Well, listen up, because restocks are the buying thing!
Oh my gosh.
When the board restocks a bunch of new pegs will fall from the sky and fill all your empty spaces.
Oh.
Northern Lion Mint Collab win.
I don't deserve that at all.
If anything, Nimmy Nightmare should have Northern Lion Collab.
I don't even know this guy.
Soon after pairs of pegs with the same number will merge into the one grid or peg.
Let's try it out.
Keep launching Nubby until you beat the goal.
Okay.
So like Oh, shoot.
I keep forgetting to press the...
Whoa!
Pegtacular!
That was peg-alicious.
You're a star.
Just kidding.
No, you're not.
Okay, we're almost done.
To rearrange your new pegs, press the jumbo button.
Whoa.
Nice.
Launch Nubby one more time.
Whoa!
Oh, gosh.
Oh, geez.
I can already feel myself.
getting addicted to this, you know.
You may have noticed that Nubi goes through some pegs, but not through others.
Nubi will break through ones, but will bounce off any peg greater than one.
Alright, bud, that's it for the tutorial.
You'll figure out the rest for yourself.
Smiley face.
Oh!
Hey!
I forgot it's on one thing!
Every time you launch Nubi, you lose one life.
If you run out of lives, the sun will explode!
But luckily, every time the board restocks, you get one life back.
So as long as you keep making big numbers, Nobody gets hurt.
Okay, I'm done.
Thanks for not pressing the skip tutorial button.
I know that was difficult for you.
I'll start you off with a fresh new factory now.
Good luck!
Oh, we're at the factory.
Zone 1!
Oh my gosh.
Sonic the Hedgehog.
2!
We'll go.
We'll go this way.
Yeah, big number.
big number?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And then you can...
Oh, okay, so you can only shuffle one.
Oops.
Wait, I hit the goal.
I haven't lived till now.
I cannot believe Min Tandem is playing my favorite game.
No, it's No Bavaccarer!
Wait, this is...
Oh, yeah, baby.
What is he doing there?
Is he tracking my progress?
So this is like Peggle.
It is like...
I guess so.
Whoa.
16?
Uh-oh.
Dang it.
That was not good.
Team.
We need to lock in.
Whoa.
Nubi-Nubi-Mart.
There's items!
Rogue-like Peggle.
Wait, that's kind of awesome.
Click an item to drag and drop it into your inventory.
Press right to sell them.
Oh, let's see.
Okay, we got...
glasses highest number peg popped pops two random pegs pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro pedro nubby hits wall pops one random peg crazy straw 10 wait what was this one disguised glasses Summons one straw that pops one peg.
Pegs popped by straws give an additional...
Wait, how much do I even have?
I have five gold.
I can't...
I can't buy any of this.
What does this do?
This is that...
This is like...
Oh, they're called the...
The bears or something, right?
Oh, oh, this is five gold for one item slot.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
I have nine.
Okay, okay.
Water bear!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
25% chance to double one random peg.
The freeze block allows you to save one item for later purchase.
Okay, I was wondering if this would either let you do that or like freeze the whole thing.
Rare item odds, 5%.
Well, how do I know if something's rare?
Will it glow?
So wait, summons one straw that pops one peg.
Pegs popped by straw gives an additional 10% of their number.
Gains 5% every time you've jumbled pegs in the game.
Wait, that sounds kind of good, though, no?
By color, maybe.
Well, I guess we'll see.
Doesn't that sound kind of good?
It's apparent it's rare.
Okay, okay, okay.
It has some scaling.
Yeah, and it might be good early game.
Oh.
Oh, interesting.
Okay, so this is what the slots are up here for.
So we have, we can get max seven items.
Nice, okay.
I played Peggle, guys.
I played Peggle.
I beat Peggle.
My good friend Emma has been wanting to get into Blue Archive, and he said this last push was needed.
It's coming, or she's telling to do so, so please convince him.
Why wouldn't you hop on Blue Archive?
Special round!
Sneaky snipers!
Hover over to see the details.
What is it?
I'm hovering?
What's the details?
Hello?
I'm hovering?
Oh,
you needed to hover over the...
Oh, okay.
Oops.
My bad.
I don't know what just happened.
But it was awesome.
Wait.
I need to restart.
I need to start doing this because.
Because of the straw.
I got loot.
Is this a red?
Oh!
The tornado perk.
Force triggers the leftmost item.
Items.
Jumbling pegs.
Increases X by plus 2.
This value resets after each round.
What is up with me playing like these kind of rope?
games, the clover pit, I'm just...
Force triggers all non-upgraded items.
I think we should go for this.
Very cute.
Oh, that didn't... Okay.
Maybe it's fine.
What was it again?
It was like...
It gives initial...
Wait.
Every time you jumbled pegs in the game okay yeah yeah yeah so we got to keep jumbling always be jumbling a bj no viewer here avenger mystery of the druids and harvest your vods during my shift and i'm obsessed if you're still in the pointy clicky games with the deranged i definitely recommend dark seed particularly the sequel i i am i am very still into clicky pointy games thank you welcome by the way a bj
No!
Always be chaplain!
Hold on, I want to see if I can bounce it off the wall.
Oh, I can.
Okay.
That was really bad.
What if it's jumbling with a G?
A, B, G.
Always be gumbling.
Flamethrower.
A random peg will explode.
Wait, I want this.
I want that.
Pops the lowest number peg twice.
Nice save.
Thank you.
Always be gambling.
YouTube don't listen don't listen I hate gambling oh no I've never gambled ever before in my afterlife I hate it I hate it I get the rocks this the ton of no this is a feather that's not a rock it's literally a feather no gambling wait
Um, gosh, I can't get over this guy because it moves so crazy.
Uh, I wonder if I should save for the flamethrower because this seems pretty good to pop random pegs nearby, I think.
He's so wiggly.
Pedro loves you, you should get him.
You can sell the straw!
What I'll do is I'll freeze.
Oh, drag and drop an item over this button to freeze them.
Frozen items won't go away when you re-roll or leave the shop.
I think I should do it.
Does Flamethrower add those points, though?
I assume.
Right?
Is that what it means?
Bejo, bejo, bejo, bejo.
Use it, it's free.
Okay.
Frozen.
We'll save, we'll save.
This is really making me want to play pebble.
I'm not going to lie.
Oh, icky.
Crappy.
Oh, nice.
Oh, yeah.
Good, good, good.
Not icky, crappy.
Better.
Okay, I'm going to bounce off the wall.
Oh, no.
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, yeah!
Oh, okay.
Hover over this to see...
Okay.
This peg will pop the highest number peg when popped.
Will not pop itself.
Okay, okay, okay.
So...
Oh.
Ah.
I think I messed up.
Oh, my gosh!
Wait, I only have the sun's about to explode!
Wait, guys!
I think we're in trouble.
Last shot!
Wait, but I thought it did every time it restocked or whatever.
Am I...
The sun isn't gonna explode.
It's blown!
Oh.
It was a good first run, was it?
You are awesome.
Lerker here, hi!
That the grumpy ghost bro on your outfit is really great and I dream of maybe being like a squishy pin or tiny plushy of it someday.
Yes, you're pretty good, too.
Please take care and enjoy your time off in November.
Zimbabwe!
Thank you.
This guy is really wobbly, isn't he?
At least I have some jiggles on me.
Nah.
Wait, but why did I die?
if it was restocking.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
That was horrible.
Oh.
Guys, this is really bad.
Wait, this is so bad.
You get one extra shot per restock.
Oh, maybe I was just wasting them too much.
Not a great peggler.
Oh, I'm the best ever Do it, please!
Believe me!
Now be more...
Ooh, squirmie.
Gives plus five points for every time this item has triggered during the round.
One in 50 chance to metamorphosize.
What does he trigger?
Uranium rod.
Always be reshuffling.
Nubi Emits a burst of nuclear waste Nuclear waste pops any pegs it touches If Nubi isn't alive, a random peg What do you mean if Nubi isn't alive?
I want to try the rod, though Seems cool If Nubi's not alive Don't you even mean this car?
Nubi could die The peg
with the high...
Okay, okay, okay.
So it's like...
Please, pop!
Pop!
No!
Nobody dies when he reaches the bottom.
Oh, that's what they mean.
That's so sad.
I got loot.
We got the speedy perk.
If the round started less than 1.5 seconds ago, force triggers the item slots in the one.
Okay.
Force triggers the leftmost item in your inventory.
I think I'll skip.
It gives me gold.
Unless, I guess I could move stuff around.
I guess I could get the speedy perk and, like, move things as I get them, maybe.
perks are usually good you'll keep the money oh Oscar am I that quick though I can be I'll be quick
we got pants oh my gosh I got two flamethrowers mom lets me have two sorry two pants This is not strike witches.
Pops a random peg.
When this peg pops, it gives a points twice.
That sounds like a tongue twister and all.
Pops a random peg.
When this peg pops, it gives points twice.
Wait, that's actually...
That's kind of good, actually, no?
What's the kazoo?
Doubles a random peg?
We already have the uranium rod, so I feel like it's kind of similar to...
Well, maybe not.
I don't know.
She'd be spitting.
Pops a random peg.
When this peg pops, it gives points twice.
I'm surprised you even know what pants are, Minto.
I wasn't born yesterday.
I died yesterday.
When's the funeral?
I'm gonna try the pants.
Pants.
Yuck.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
Well, how many points are we at?
I wonder.
Compared to last time, you know?
Okay.
Sneaky snipers!
Oh, they're all the way down there!
Wait, we can refresh?
Wait, no, that sucks!
Wait!
Woo!
Oh!
Good run.
Yes?
Why are we saying yes?
Oh, I don't mean to be rude.
I don't mean to be rude, but what are you?
Are you an elf?
A ghost?
A maid?
A nerd?
Did you just say nerd?
That's one of Lives and Afterlives Tough choices, tough questions What are we If I am but a ghost mid Nerd elf What are you?
What do you desire to be?
If you can think it, you can be it.
If you want to be a little crab that makes those holes in the sand when the water is wet and it's kind of like bubbling a little bit, you could do it.
inspirational.
Get me on TED Talk.
Why?
Who?
Who is TED anyway?
And why do I have to listen to him?
Huh?
I don't get it.
I don't get that guy.
I don't know him.
Oh, no!
That was so bad!
No!
Maybe here?
Come on!
Yeah!
The Gravitron!
It's only six gold, which I try.
Why is Ted talking?
And why do we listen to him?
Key?
Go for the key?
Caffeinated Minto's mind is too powerful.
We must become fiddler crabs and take down Ted and cease his talking.
Beep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
When opened, receive a suspicious key.
Suspicious key on the next shop turn, you will gain access to the black market.
You guys are telling me to do illegal activities.
Nah, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
If I live to see the day of the black market.
Oh, okay, good.
Sneaky snipers.
Sneaky sniper.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, was that?
I don't think that was good, was it?
Oh, geez.
I'm using the key.
Oh, snub.
Clarity.
My cat has like a nub-tail.
So when you say that, it makes me think of my cat.
Alien.
What does she alien?
A random peg amidst a cosmoblast.
When a peg is popped by a cosmoblast, it counts as two pegs popped instead of one.
Putaroya.
Yeah, he's got a little nub-tail.
Flibby flobbies.
the item to the left of me wants.
Oh, so it is, like, where you can rearrange these, okay.
Oh, man.
Oh, mannequin head.
I was close.
Reduces round gold by... 30%!
Wait, but it's corrupted.
This item cannot be forced triggered.
Halfs all pegs.
Oh, that's not good, though.
This one is rare.
The yellow text is the trigger for items, by the way.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
Two pegs doubled.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
All perks force triggered the item to the left of me.
But it's rare, so I want to get it.
Flippy flobbies.
Oh, I could reroll.
Because flippy flobbies...
Wouldn't even account for these, you know?
I don't know.
The rare is really good, is it?
Okay, I'll get the fluby-flubbers.
Pleasure doing business with you.
Power outage.
This peg will disable a random item when fully popped.
Disabled items cannot trigger for the rest of the round.
Sorry.
Oh my god!
Don't do it.
Oh, that was so close.
Holy cow.
I got loot.
Cheese.
The cheesy perk.
Force triggers all items.
Nubby dies.
Force triggers all Nubby dies items again.
I think maybe this one.
The cheesy perk.
Cheese, cheese, cheese, cheese.
Squeak, squeak.
We made it to zone two.
The stratosphere.
Oh my gosh, I've been there before!
Uh-oh.
Team.
This might be it.
Oh!
Oh my gosh, oh my gosh!
Oh, golly!
It's too much pressure!
Stay
in love Stay in love Poop butt For every time the board has restocked this game Gain 15 points Summons a sharp shot That will pop a random peg Ten times Monstrosity Wait what is this one?
Jax If Nubby is still alive Summon a meat orb That will float around and pop pegs Meat orb dies when Nabi dies.
Jack's to the left of your rare item is busted.
Oh, let's try it.
Okay, I'll try it.
I just believed you.
Could you say Pico is the best?
He's my dog.
I just believed you.
Come on, last shot!
Never be game over!
Good job, team.
That was pretty good.
Good job.
Good job, everybody.
Whoa, so many restocks.
Maybe I'm good at this game.
Oh,
we have some new characters.
Creative upload!
I hope you're having a nubbatastic day.
Not quite how I would imagine the sun exploding.
What is this guy?
Finger puppet.
Nubby gives points equal to the number of times that Nubby has bounced this round.
Okay.
We could go back with the uranium rod.
That is reroll free.
Reroll is free once per store.
I'm gonna reroll.
Wow!
Flame in skull!
20...
Nubby dies.
10% chance to cause a giant explosion that pops all pegs at once.
40% chance if you are on your last shot.
Whoa!
Sun exploding.
What is this?
Outer wilds?
Bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang, bang.
Not a lot, though.
C.
Cucumber.
Every empty peg space will give points equal to the amount of total pegs that have been popped in this row.
PPS!
Like, you're pretty good in my last donut was meant to be an oscillating.
Yeah, I know.
PPS.
You're actually really great.
Two.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Broken socket.
Item to the right of me triggers.
25% to create a chain bolt that pops a cluster of pegs.
Oh, but there's nothing to the right of the broken socket that would trigger.
So...
Maybe a meat orb.
Yeah, too early for it.
Let's try the meat orb.
Let's just see how he works.
Seems kind of fun.
Whoa!
Oh wow, that sucked.
Gold Rush, this peg will give plus one coin when popped for the first time.
I work a nine to five now!
Old username!
Oh, seven.
Get that, make that, make that.
Sweet, sweet cash, though, you know?
Is he actually doing anything?
Ooh, we got loot.
We got Force Trigger all X-Pegs popped items.
Nubby dies.
Force Trigger's all first-Pegs popped items.
Wait, what?
Oh, I have neither.
Maybe the Nubby dies because that is a given.
Well, I guess 15 pegs popped would also maybe be a given, but...
Rip nubby.
Skipper, you think so?
Zombie.
Zombie seems dope.
I lost my job, you don't!
Yeah!
Money is important early on.
Okay, I'm going to skip this one.
It might be against my better judgment, but...
You know what I always say?
This is a classic phrase from classic Minto.
OG Minto.
Way, way back in 2020.
People last.
I bleep.
It's real.
So inspired.
Mm-hmm.
Wise words.
And that's a rock fact.
Let's see.
I gotta get Pedro, maybe.
Or the flamethrower.
Every one second.
Wait.
Can I get more than one item at a time?
Jax is good.
Guys, that was terrible.
Whoa!
Oh, wait.
Maybe I can bounce off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There we go.
Gold Rush!
You.
I think I got it.
Did I?
Wait, I'm not making...
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
there we go wait oh my gosh no i didn't make it at all wait this sucks uh-oh team this might be it
no okay don't buy both don't buy both actually wait
she killed the song I'm going to hell and I'm taking you with me!
What a happy seal!
Two random pegs get smacked.
When a peg is smacked, it counts as a peg halved.
Trigger without actually halving.
Hal- hal- hal- halving it.
Hell with me, though!
Yippee!
I don't know what but it is but listening to you makes me feel very relaxed today.
My brain feels smooth as a minto's bottom.
My bottom is really smooth.
I lotion it every day.
There's a song by Leve that I really like.
That's it's kind of cute because it's like.
How does it go?
If I like hear it obviously I know.
Oh it's called like the silver it's called silver lining.
It's really cute because it's like.
Like, you know, we're being baddies, but if I'm going to hell, the silver lining is that I'm going to hell with you, baby.
So cute.
Jarvis, clip that.
I'm going to go.
Oh, maybe I will go for the feathers this time.
Or the rod.
I feel like the uranium rod helped us a lot before, so maybe...
Would you recommend putting lotion on booties?
I lotion everywhere.
You should lotion everywhere.
The old Lave lotion bottom song.
I'm familiar.
Yeah, yeah.
Uranium, my favorite.
I think so, too.
I think I like it also.
Phew!
Oh, nice, nice.
Oh, yeah, baby.
Yeah, baby.
Cool restock too.
Restock too.
Restock.
Come on, come on.
Get back in there.
Come on.
There we go.
Kaizel, welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, the sound effects in this game are great, though.
Let's see what we got here.
We got the springy perk.
5% chance to force trigger item in slot 5, which I do not have unlocked.
The archaic perk.
Force triggers all non-unlocked.
Upgraded items.
Well, I have no...
Numbers are hard.
Yeah.
I just hate the feel of lotion at first.
I do it right after I get out of the shower.
So I'm still kind of like...
You know, I'm still a little damp from the shower.
And then I just stand there naked while the lotion dries.
I sometimes move my body like this.
To help.
With my arms out.
I become like a windmill.
Air drawing.
What should I... I don't know.
I feel like this one probably helps us in the short term.
Which is dumb.
You should never...
You should always be thinking long term.
But what the hell?
Oh, lobster claw.
Every item in your inventory gives points equal to a random peg's number.
Well, we can't afford it, though.
Oh, my gosh, Cheese House!
Wait, there's so many friends here.
I like you as a friend.
I'm glad!
We're just, we're just bros.
Oh, I can freeze it.
You're right.
What is this?
Nubby dies gained 300 points.
If you were on round 30 or higher, gained 3,000 points instead.
That could be life or death.
Nubi hits wall twice.
Doubles four random pegs whose number is less than 32.
Wait, huh?
Wait.
Doubles four random pegs whose number...
Oh, okay.
Cheesehouse is early carry.
If I get this, though, would I be able...
If I freeze you...
Can I freeze it again?
Can I freeze it?
More than once.
Oh, two, three!
Five!
Five restock!
Yes, ma'am.
Thank you.
Thank you, ma'am.
Okay, these are the guys.
We're doing crazy restock numbers!
Oh, my gosh!
Crazy numbers!
do i do it do i go for the black market what's the mystery wait i will have i should have wait what black market
this game i can this is this is a super like turn your brain off kind of game holy moly guys this is crazy turn your brain off Just let Nubby do his thing.
And just enjoy.
Four times!
Come on, come on, give me, give me the gold!
Oh, yeah, we got it.
Nice.
I will be buying this game.
It's great!
This is awesome!
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no.
Oh, we made it.
We made it.
Wait, but...
What about...
What about the other...
What about the lobster claw?
It stays frozen, it does.
It's still there.
Lopter.
Wingless fly.
If the first peg popped is the highest number peg, multiply total score by 2.5.
Wait, that's kind of good.
Snake.
Ouroboros.
Wait!
Snake!
Jake the snake!
One and two chance to double all pegs.
Mm-hmm.
Amidst one...
Echors?
Ech.
I-core.
Twin snakes.
You love Jake.
One and two chance to double all pegs.
I feel like this guy is kind of good though.
too though no oh it's the first peg popped oh my gosh wait that'd be crazy but i think we should go for jake wait everybody likes jake we're going for jake ikker ikker
jake is huge jake's our man jake jake he's our man if we can't do it whoa oh Boss round!
This peg will kill Nubi and end the round when fully popped!
Not good.
Not cool.
Oh my gosh!
How do we do it?
Mystery box perk.
If slot 1 is empty, a random item from Nubi Mart will appear in slot 1 and force trigger 3 times!
The new item will disappear at the end of the round.
Nubby almost died for real, you guys.
Force triggers all items every three seconds.
Cheese is better here, mystery is good way early.
I guess that's true.
We're back to the stratosphere!
Okay we're making it, we're making it.
Ish.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, okay, okay.
Corrupted items like Jake can't be forced triggered, though.
He's been doing a good job at his job, though.
He's been doing a good job.
Good job, Jake.
Oh!
Okay, what I'm going to do is I'm going to unlock the item slot, and we're going to buy
the lobster Claw.
Five pegs pop.
Summons one quill that falls from the sky and pops one peg.
Oh, I can upgrade!
Ooh, white cheese.
13 fonts!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Move Jake out of three.
Why?
Moldy cheese.
No Swiss cheese.
We're cheesing it up.
Re-roll, let's try it.
Whoa!
Oh my gosh.
If only I had enough money, I could make it crazy.
I could make it go crazy if we could do all three.
Can buy one and freeze the other, but it's true.
Minto!
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
I think it's okay, though.
Well, I don't know.
I feel like getting upgrades at this point is probably pretty good, I think.
Maybe.
The perk forces the first three slots.
Yeah.
You don't have items that triggers a lot.
I think this one triggers...
Well, so...
Oh, it's only triggers from the first...
peg popped.
Nobody dies.
Every three seconds.
This one's every three seconds.
It could be good.
Love this game.
Number goat op simulator.
Wolf snake into four or five.
Wait, why?
Wait.
My perk.
Force triggers all non-upgraded.
But now it's upgraded.
Oops.
Alright, Force Triggers all items.
But does the order matter for those?
What is this?
Oh, neat!
Whoa!
Yeah, the cheese perk activates all, no?
Besides this.
Right?
Yeah, my current perks don't care about slots.
That's what I thought.
I was like, am I going crazy?
Only this one triggers to the right.
I think we're okay.
I think we can keep going.
Well, I say that.
I don't know.
This is my first time playing the game.
Me acting like a stinking note all over here.
Oh my gosh.
Oh.
Oh, geez.
Psychic link.
All psychic pegs will give points equal to their number when any psychic peg is popped.
What does that mean?
three more rounds and cheese house starts carrying true true because we got to make to 30.
uh oh wait that was not a okay we're hanging on we're hanging on okay nice we got loot springy perk 5 chance for force trigger item and five force triggers a side slot can buy thank you so much for the pocketed force triggers the item in slot seven two times for each empty inventory slot neither of these kind of help neither of these void is absolutely busted when you build around it that's the thing right now though is i don't know any sort of build what
could be good in five besides maybe the this one or...
Oh, wait, wait, wait!
If we do five for this one every three seconds...
Okay.
It could force it to be...
Only 5% chance, but, you know.
I think it's better than nothing.
Oh.
That was terrible.
That was terrible!
There we go.
We made it to round 30!
Upgrade the lobster claw!
Let's go.
What is it?
What will it do, though?
Every enemy room.
The claw.
I don't have so much.
So much.
What's it called, though?
Money.
Doubles the value.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
What's the value?
value so what or would it be like four two what not quite sure what these numbers mean
what this guy do the mouse the finger puppet nubby gives points equal to the number of times that nubby has bounced this round
oh horse horse pill chance to double the highest number peg.
Ultra rare, ultra rare.
E block.
Force trigger this item.
When this is force triggered, it transfers the force trigger to the item to the left of me.
Has a 15% chance to add an additional...
Wait, add on one plus one additional force trigger.
Wait!
I could also upgrade.
I think I should haunt though.
I don't have enough money to upgrade.
That sucks.
Oh, well.
I don't have enough money for anything.
Well, shoot.
Oh, well.
We continue onwards.
Onwards and upwards.
Nice.
Oh, okay.
That was close.
Me-ham!
This peg will explode and pop eight pegs in a cross pattern when popped for the first time.
Whoa!
Holy score!
Crazy!
Oh my gosh.
We're going crazy!
Tonight!
We are crazy!
Oh!
All seeing pyramid.
This item emits a god ray.
The god ray rapidly pops a random peg once for each time the item is in slot.
Wait, the item in slot one has triggered this round.
Wait, that sounds kind of awesome.
though, but I can only get probably two things.
I think we should get the horse.
We'll get the horse.
I have to upgrade my... I have to expand.
What I could do
is freeze him.
Freeze the god ray.
Get this, and expand, and then I'll get this next time.
Cool.
Wait, can I upgrade?
I can't!
Oh, why not?
How many times can you upgrade?
No, I can't.
Well, that's sad.
Can only upgrade once.
Okay, okay, okay.
If I had another upgraded cheese house, like, say, in another slot, Could I then combine them?
Buy two slots.
Oh, I guess I could, right?
No.
Only once.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
What was this again?
Oh!
Might be good to get another one, though, right?
I mean...
Two cheese houses would be kind of great, because then we could get 7,500 plus another 3,000.
Why not?
And then I can unlock.
And then I could sell them later.
It's all good.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, that was not a...
Oh, no way.
No, I have like no gold.
Why?
What is the tree?
Half's the highest number peg.
Doubles the lowest number peg two times.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to expand.
Cafe.
Cafe Nabi.
Drag and drop food items into the mouth to eat.
Kidney bean.
Stocks a random rare food item.
Mid cafe.
Oh,
that was bad.
not good.
This peg will break after it has been popped for the first time.
Okay.
Oh, like that.
Cute doll!
Horse triggers all first peg popped items.
Which is that.
If slot one is empty, a random...
Oh, this is the... This is the gotcha perk.
Hmm.
Meantau.
Sweetau.
Minto, cuto, say it back.
Yeah, my inventory will be full.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Maybe we just go with zombie then.
I'm just going to go with zombie.
Or I could get the money.
Hmm.
I do need money.
Actually, I think we have a few rounds, though, before the next shop.
So I think it's okay.
Meantos, zombo.
I'll go with zombie.
We're on the moon!
Wow!
Wee!
Glad
you have to go over there.
Why couldn't you go here?
Hmm.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
How many rounds are there?
I still don't have enough?
T-t.
Force...
T-block.
100% chance to force trigger both on.
items to the left and right of me.
Odds decreased by 20% for each time this success late triggers.
Odds reset to 100% when the round is over.
Nita!
Kita!
Sell Cheese House!
But we're still using Cheese House.
Check the cafe.
Some food give you coins back.
Oh, really?
Let's see.
Cute!
Get one coin for every strawberry during this game maxes out at seven coins.
Wait.
So I...
I...
Wait, I eat the strawberry.
Wait, what?
What is this?
A pickle rat.
Upon returning to Nubimart, gain one Riro.
It's an investment.
Spend three, gain one.
So I guess you start making the money back once you once you eat three strawberries.
Is that the thing?
You can sell the lowered ranked cheese.
How do I sell it actually?
Oh, right click.
It's four gold.
It's an investment in my future!
Still wondering if I should get the strawberry.
But a max is out at seven.
When do I get the coin?
Is it at the end of every round?
Right now.
Ah, oh, okay.
Investment, investment, investing in my future!
Holy cow!
Holy points, you guys!
Nine restocks!
Say tease!
This peg gives points twice when popped.
Docs!
I might be the best.
Oh.
Don't look at that one.
That didn't count.
Uh oh.
Wait.
Oh geez.
I'm throwing.
I made it!
I lived!
This again?
I think Maybe we should do...
Maybe we move this to...
Slot 5 since it has the force trigger.
We blame Nubby on those?
Or wait, hold on.
Or...
I don't know.
Will this go to 10%?
It just says 2.
So I can't tell.
Random peg value could be low, that's true.
Let's try it, let's see how this works.
Whoa, no!
Holy cow!
Wait, it worked out so well!
What the heck is this?
Asbestos!
Summons a clump of insulation that falls from the sky!
When insulation touches a peg, it gives 5%, 10% of the round goal.
Galatian does not pop pegs.
Hmm.
Squirmy!
Gives five points for every time the item has triggered during this round.
One and five.
Oh, the metamorphosize.
You don't have many items that have pegs, though.
For what?
Oh, I just realized about the...
Randomly pops a...
Wait.
Random... rapidly pops a random peg for each time the item in slot 1 is triggered.
Well, it triggered pretty... a lot, actually.
I think the spring helped.
Oh, when three pegs halved!
Oh, I keep forgetting to look at how...
It's triggered.
Ouch.
Oh, sorry.
I just have run out of you.
I missed Oji Day because of work, but thanks.
Thanks for being the best copy of Shigapassi.
Ask where I lurk in a lot of streams and watch mods at work.
I'm so proud to call me by Oji.
Eric!
That's...
That's all I could ever ask.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Oh, you can click on the Ion.
That's right.
Whoa.
I don't know what times 13 means, but it seems huge.
I think we might want to get the T block and, like, put it in between these two or something.
Or, like, maybe Jake even.
Oh, wait.
Jake can't be forced.
That's right.
Never mind.
Or maybe horse.
Put it in between these two.
T-block and five?
That's what I'm thinking.
Let's try it.
Is this how many times...
This is how...
It can't be how many times they're activated.
I don't know.
Squirmion one.
Trust.
Reroll.
This one's...
good
eight pegs popped oh yeah the cafe whoa i take this chip and i eat it if you have less than maximum lives restore one live otherwise re-rolls cafe foods hi dog dog in one coin for each remaining life way to have five lives that'd be pretty good i would get two back two free
roll for strobe though gives one kebab perk nobody dies 50 chance to force trigger the right most item in your inventory what did i play that oh volatro this is just like volatro where like the order of everything matters yeah
we'll probably eat something i'm just trying to decide what
free money
wait I well it's 11 coins I'm not gonna 11 coins for for a re-roll I think I might kebab what if we move these three you know this could be the this could be I don't know why I'm like thinking the god ray you know I don't know
stack kebab
Where do the kebab perks go?
How am I even supposed to see where they're at?
We're at round 50, guys.
We're killing it.
The books.
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
T-box at 5?
Oh, that's right.
Yes, yes, yes.
That's right.
Wait, but then what do we put in 7?
I guess that's fine there too.
Whoa, what is this?
Oh, I have the eyeball on, that's why.
Super score!
Uh-oh, wait, uh-oh, wait, uh-oh, wait, uh-oh, wait, uh-oh.
Oh, we made it, we made it, we made it, we made it, team.
That was pretty scary.
Booger party!
Wind pop this peg will emit two snout shots That pop any pegs they pass through Okay Oh geez Uh oh wait this is bad This might be bad news bears
Oh my gosh Whoa whoa whoa Oh no no no
Oh we made it We made it Oh that was close I was scared I was scared guys Uh-oh, oh,
where's our big guy?
All the way down there?
Okay, uh...
52 rounds.
Board clears.
Wow, okay.
Overachievers over here.
This is just Bilatro Bapaliko.
Yes.
I want a board clear.
Okay.
I want a board clear, but I also just want to play the game.
It was a pixel perfect shot.
One point.
Oh, dang it.
I thought it would, like, bounce over to in here.
What do we got?
What do we got at the mart?
Nabi mart.
Nabi marty.
Yeah, Nubimart.
Oh, flaming skull.
I needed you.
When a peg is smacked, it cannot just peg half.
Get the skull?
Yeah.
Bread to the bones.
Let's try it.
Doesn't hurt to try something, right?
Unless you freaking die.
Wait, what?
How does it say?
Oh, Nubby dies.
That's right.
I was like, how does this trigger again?
Okay, Skull, I need you to do your job.
I need you to do your job.
Please.
No!
I got some loot.
It's shaking its head.
Whoa!
The Warlock perk.
Force triggers all Nubby dies items again.
Well...
Force triggers all items.
I think cheese
Cheese, my beloved Oh,
we haven't seen Whoa, whoa Guys, these are all rare Whoa, whoa Whoa, I maybe got the luckiest Store ever Oh my god Oh my god How How, how, how Wait, oh my gosh.
Okay, we gotta sell the skull.
We gotta sell the skull.
Okay, what I think I'll do is I'll freeze one nose and get the other nose.
But what's this?
Laser pointer triggers an electron beam that passes through pegs when the electron beam hits a peg.
The peg will give 50% of its number.
Electron beams do not pop pegs.
Wait, the laser sounds so good too, though.
Inflatable dolphin summons a beach ball that emits five streams of confetti when it pops.
by confetti give 125% right these all sound so good
Miranda peg will emit three snout shots that pop any pegs they pass through cheesy minto recipe google please freaking cute
the reason I want to get the nose is because we have two we can just basically upgrade almost immediately We have to pass the round goal, though.
Two pegs halved.
I don't have anything that halves.
Unless I have no items that will halve it.
Laser is good once you get the seal.
Okay, I'll get the laser.
For as an investment.
Is there anything you guys think I should...
Freeze.
Nubby dies.
This could be like a save...
Like it saves the round kind of thing, you know?
Freeze the nose?
Okay, we'll freeze the nose.
Dang, what a crazy pull!
Holy moly.
Oh, oh, there we go.
Oh!
I still shot it.
Oh, that was terrible.
No!
Adrigo!
Thank you so much, brother!
Tawani gifted, gosh, I don't recognize you at all!
With your new profile picture.
Month one of asking Vito to marry me.
But you've been a member for five months!
Another game I need to buy, thanks for the great shoes Vito!
Of course!
Thank you so much for the super chat!
Wanderic Zero, welcome back!
Oh, no, no, no!
That was bad.
Wait, did I just...
Oh my gosh, I just did the same exact thing.
No, please.
Guys, I'm throwing!
I'm throwing!
Oh my god.
Please, please, please.
I need a hero!
Oh!
I'm on it!
I'm for a hero!
No!
I'm sorry guys!
I threw, I threw!
That was terrible!
You know how in Peggle you can be extremely precise?
With like...
Moving the mouse very slightly will change.
I thought it would be more like that, you know?
Uh, hello?
Okay.
I get it.
I understand.
You don't throw, you bounce.
Marriage proposal number 18.
I deleted your memory before.
How?
Time, bones.
Welcome to membership, thank you.
Is cactus good?
I kind of want to try it.
Fragetti beam.
Why can't I ever get the spaghetti beam?
Mouse wheel might find...
Oh, well, I'll try it.
I'll try it.
Ouch.
I think I got a bug bite.
It's good, but it's really good when it's upgraded.
Okay, let's aim for upgrade then.
Oh, we got all our lives back.
Let's go.
Itty.
Itty-o-shey.
No.
Thank you
so much for that, Tawani!
Went to marry Minto for 1,000 years, spaghetti dinners.
Oh, spaghetti dinners!
Okay, wait a second.
Force triggers all non-upgraded items.
The chaotic perk.
Force triggers one random item every second.
Wait, that could be good if it's a second?
Every second?
But this is every one and a half seconds.
Hmm.
I always want to cause a chaos.
Oh.
Oh, I forgot.
Oh, see, look how much it's going now.
Seal, where were you?
Where were you?
Where were you when I needed you?
Bedrope, bedrope, bedrope, bedrope, burn.
Come out!
Thank you for the tiny gift.
Thank you.
Later on, you have almost all slash most upgraded items.
Right, right, right.
First ever Super Chat, and it's on my birthday!
Look at that, my kamiyoshi streaming today.
Shiny hunting a ghastly!
Good luck!
Happy birthday!
Wait.
Huh.
Feliz Complianios!
Did I say it right?
I did?
I remembered!
Yippee!
It was perfect!
Happy.
I'm gonna get sealed and I'm gonna pray.
We get the laser beam again.
That's the build we're going for.
That's the build.
Oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh,
land...
Oh, jeez.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, I shouldn't have...
I shouldn't have re-ruled.
I thought I might get something better.
Please!
Ah.
Are you gonna stream on the 29th of this month, or do you still not know?
That is a great question.
Does it happen to be your birthday on the 29th?
I can check my schedule.
I can check my calendar literally right now, and I can tell you.
Oh, wait, there's actually a possibility.
There's actually a possibility of me being able to stream that day.
But, well, it might be...
It might be the 28th your time, though.
Time zone.
yeah
I'll do my best to stream in the later part of the month as much as I can because I'm accidentally taking off so many days I'm so sorry guys oh wait I could get a mystery but I could save the gold
take the rest when you need it it's okay I will have plenty of days off as well honestly speaking i'll be back the i can't even remember the seventh i will be back or the eighth i can't remember so there's also like a whole other week after after uh the november dates so my wife ordered your wet rose cosplay whose idea was it to add the pantsuit to the set and was that part of your original concept art well yes my my my pantsu are part of my my they're on my reference sheet
yeah but um i don't know why they included it i don't get like get commission or anything don't don't get me wrong like there i don't get i didn't like work with wet rose to to produce that or anything it's not like official i i have no idea who decided that the pants should be included but i tried them on they
were a little they were a little small the rest of the outfit fit perfect This is just the panties that were too small.
The new wisp uniform.
Oh my gosh, I hope there's an army next con.
I'm very happy to have an accurate headband.
Yeah!
Oh, so...
I'm gonna try...
Wait.
Just because I haven't tried it yet, I want to get a mystery.
Oh.
I don't get it.
that mystery.
When opened, 85% chance to receive a random common item.
8% chance to receive a random common perk.
5% chance to receive a random rare item.
2% chance to receive a random rare perk.
Rare perk and hoi!
Oh.
Got a water bear.
Wait, what does this guy do?
Oh, the peg is halved.
Let's go gambling.
Hoi!
No, no, no, no!
YouTube, I didn't say that!
YouTube, I said nothing.
YouTube, I didn't say that.
I didn't say that at all.
This is not gambling.
There's no gambling involved.
You guys are literally gonna get me cancelled.
I knew I should have re-done this one.
Oh my gosh!
There we go.
Ripvod!
It actually gave me a warning though, which means if I got...
If I had gotten anything more?
Like, or rather... Oh, we can upgrade the cactus!
Like say I got... say...
Um...
Say I got another warning, it would actually turn into a strike and like actually affect my channel.
Like, it's so freaky.
The warning was dismissed, luckily.
Once they, once they determined that my...
Oh gosh.
Oh no, no!
Once they determined that my VOD was okay, but like...
So close!
If they hadn't determined that it was okay, like, if I had gotten any more warnings, it would have turned into a strike.
And people were telling me they were like, oh, it's the new...
It's the new YouTube policy, but apparently said policy says that it won't be enacted until later this month.
So there was no reason for them to actually have gone after me.
So I don't know if maybe...
I'm hoping that like they're not like, oh yeah, it was fun.
For now.
I saw the calendar and you have only like four days off.
Oh, it's okay.
So, whoa!
Dance and Dino!
60% chance to do nothing.
20% chance to double one random peg.
20% chance to half one random peg.
If Nubby bounces, that's crazy.
Oh, we could get some pants.
but yeah so i don't know i hope that they don't like say that it was fine and then once they put in that rule even though the rule the rule is insane they're like no gambling no gambling and also i'm even afraid to say the word oh my gosh and they're like oh they say that you can't do that And it's also,
like, even if it's not real money.
So I'm like, I can't play, like, you can't play, like, blackjack anymore.
You can't do anything anymore.
Stop saying the G word.
What happens with people that play, like, gotcha games?
Yeah, it's so crazy.
It's, like, actually crazy.
Obviously, I understand, like, why...
They would want...
Because some stuff, like, kind of goes insane.
But...
I don't know.
Let's go juggling.
Oi!
I'm nervous.
I don't think Bellatra would be affected.
Loop boxes equals...
Equals...
Juggling?
So nobody could stream Fortnite anymore?
Wait, does Fortnite does have loot boxes, right?
Why am I crazy?
Do you like carbonara or other pasta dishes?
What's your favorite Italian food?
I love pasta.
I think the Google App Store tried to restrict Bellatro.
No stinking way!
No way.
I'm gonna get the dinosaur because he's cute.
We're gonna go dino.
Everybody do the dinosaur.
It was simi- is it gambling?
Bilatro!
Am I crazy?
Do I not know what gambling is?
I mean juggling?
Uh oh.
It's basically poker so it's juggling.
Oh, I
see.
Oh, what's that?
The sneaky perk.
Item in slot 2 triggers.
Force triggers all items.
Disables the item in slot 2.
Or the ray gun.
40% chance to force trigger the item in slot 3.
Money juggling is also juggling.
these have money belatra doesn't have money clover pit doesn't have money but snake perk is made for jake the snake let's get jake the snake with it yeah if i live to see the day i want to live i want to live oh no i might not live i might not live to see the day oh i live to see the day
Jax and Cactus seem quite similar.
Actually, I'll do Cactus because it's just five pegs popped.
Why am I doing so poorly?
Probably because I'm a little distracted.
Sorry, guys.
Oh.
Okay.
New game, that was terrible.
Thanks a lot, Nubby.
Thanks for nothing.
Wow, that was so bad.
He heard my...
Cries of anguish.
These are terrible, Nubi.
Come on!
We got a quota to meet!
We'll go back with the cactus.
We need the numbers.
We need big numbers.
How do we get big numbers?
By scoring big prizes.
oh dang it i keep forgetting to try and okay so the scroll wheel does not um does not pinpoint your your shot in case anybody was curious
you're too peggle brain i think so 10 pegs pro popped the drainer force triggers the left most item in your inventory.
Lose 3% of your total points.
Drain gang.
Yeah, the game's not really about precision.
No.
Doesn't seem to be that way.
I just noticed that this game has seeds too.
That's crazy.
I guess all kind of rogue like games like this have seeds.
This game is really fun.
Happy to see you playing it.
It's so fun!
Drainer perk was buffed.
Was it not before?
I guess force triggers the leftmost item in your inventory is pretty good.
But the chaotic perk with... I only have...
Technically speaking, anything with random anythings has a seed.
Yeah, but I've noticed it more where they'll...
where games are like showing it.
They'll be like, oh, here's the seed number.
Just kind of, like, out in the open.
It used to be 15%?
Wow.
I'm going to go chaotic.
We're playing it safe.
We got our health back.
Let's go.
I'm going to re-roll.
Wait.
No, sorry.
I was thinking of Jake the snake.
me your seed.
I mean, I can move if you want it, but because it's right behind me, you can kind of see the numbers.
The numbers, the numbers!
Squirmy!
I could try the crazy straw again.
I jumble with pegs a lot, so I think I'll try crazy straw again.
nice that
was my hannah montana you know like when they're transitioning from one scene to another then they're like oh yeah
See in transition?
I can't get the key.
I could... Wait, how much gold do I get those?
And then if I get this again, do I get...
1 to 10 coins.
No!
For someone like me, though, that's just a normal straw.
Is it because...
Oh, I would have to play again!
Oh, I'm an idiot.
Whatever.
one single coin oof oof go for the key I should have that was my bad not locked in hard enough you guys oh did I make it was that Is this a new round?
We made it?
Whoa!
Two-headed toy doll.
10 pegs pop.
The lowest number peg gives points equal to 10 times its number.
If the lowest peg is 64 or less, it will give 1000 plus points instead.
Oh, we could upgrade the cactus.
Let's do that.
Do do do.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Wait, what's a big...
What's a big carry?
This guy?
I imagine, so...
I'm gonna freeze him.
Freeze!
Holy!
What was this saying again?
The peg disables a random item when fully popped.
Oh, that's right.
Scary.
Oh, geez.
Oh, hi.
You're gonna poop in your papa!
Oh, no.
No, no, no!
Uh-oh.
Why did you bounce like that?
Ugh.
Why?
Why, indeed.
Oh, team.
It's pretty tough out here for us.
I bounced on it too crazy.
You know it.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Bounce on it, die yo.
I want to try the asbestos.
I want to try it.
Oh.
Bounce.
We still made it somehow.
A-bestos!
Wait, I don't see the asbestos happening at all, though.
Where is it?
Where's all the asbestos?
Isn't it supposed to be raining?
Someone's a clump of insulation that falls from the sky.
Where is it touching?
Oh, the trigger.
Oh.
I
didn't even have it.
Gamers can't read.
Oh, lunar perk.
triggers the item in slots six one time for every seven rounds you've passed speedy perk oh my gosh i once did at like a i guess you would call it a somewhat fancy hotel in japan it was like an art gallery hotel and i quite liked it a little i liked it a little bit i quite liked it not so much
It was like they would have like a bunch of different art installations and stuff.
And one of the paintings literally looked like this.
It looked like a little stick man running.
Hold on, let me see if I can find it.
I definitely took a picture because I was like, this is ass.
It was like $1,000 for a stick man running.
It was crazy!
I was like, this is actually crazy.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
This is the time I went.
It was definitely this year, so...
I have the images somewhere.
Hold on.
Brief intermission.
While I search for this...
This stupid painting.
It looked like...
Even worse, it looked like it was done in paint.
Like it was...
I can't get over how bad it was.
It was so silly.
Nya nya nya.
Makes it better.
I know.
It was like...
Don't get me wrong.
It was funny.
But for the price...
I was like, no, don't do this.
Not for that price.
Um, oh, maybe...
No, it wasn't this trip.
Eee!
I don't take that many photos.
I know I took a picture of it, though.
I know I did.
Where are you?
Wait.
I may be in here.
I think I give up.
I give up so fast.
And I'm so sorry.
I really can't find it.
If I find it, I'll post it on Twitter.
It's going to bother me, though.
You know?
When you're like, are looking for something?
Or you're trying to think of something?
And it's like, it's stuck in your brain.
And you're like, I can't move on.
Will I find it?
That's how I feel right now.
Even though I'm like...
I'm causing a holdup.
A holdup of my...
stream.
Wee!
Look up, Ringo's stars are.
All of it is in MSP and it's terrible.
I don't want to see.
We don't want to see it.
Went to a fancy art gallery with my husband years ago.
We saw a floor-to-ceiling canvas with the charcoal outline of the Superman S.
It was like 3K.
No way.
Ringo Star Artwork.
Oh, wow.
Every single one is like a zoomed-in picture of somebody's face.
The man can't.
If you give me a chance, ma'am, I'll hold it up.
What are you holding up?
Maybe.
Hold on.
I'm going to give it one last shot.
I'm going to look a little bit slower.
A little slower.
Just a wink slower.
I have some funny pictures in here.
Oh yeah, no, I don't think.
Unless?
Oh, maybe I deleted it.
What am I an idiot?
Why did I...
Wait, wait.
Was it earlier this year?
I could have sworn it was, like, later this year.
Hum, hum, hum, hum, hum.
Totally worth it.
I'm going to show you guys and you're going to be like...
You're gonna be like, okay, cool story.
I'm gonna be like, isn't this picture crazy?
And you're gonna be like, you're gonna be like, this is not worth the 20 minute.
Wait!
Oh, I think I just found the hotel.
Okay, we're close.
Oh my gosh, it was earlier this year.
It's worse than I remember
Wait, it's so much worse than I remember Does it have the price on it?
Oh my gosh Okay, hold on, I'm sending it to myself I'm in tears
It's so horrible Okay, hold on Alright, are you guys ready?
Here you go The bid is starting at $1,000 For I would like to call this Marathon
It's so much worse than I remember Yeah Oh my gosh!
It's art!
L.M.
He goes crazy!
Oh, look at the hands!
Look at the jagged line work!
oh it's so funny and i it was right next to my like hotel room so i would walk by it every day i would just be like this pisses me off
i'm going to do this one we can start force triggering oh the asbestos come on asbestos More asbestos!
Or we could get the uranium.
Rod!
Thank you for sharing that with us, Minky.
Was it worth like the five minute, ten minute intermission?
That only triggers if you die fast.
Oh, did I read wrong?
Oopsie!
Oh, wait, okay.
I'm playing the game now, I'm playing the game.
the game gold rush what
a terrible setup it was worth it i'm glad it was better than i hoped i remember it being really bad but like i said i didn't remember it being it was it was definitely worse than i remembered oh the gravatron If I get the gold, can I get the key?
Always be the reason someone thinks what is wrong with rich people.
I'm so rich, I get MS paint drawings on my wall.
Ten!
Three.
No!
Okay, ten!
Ten!
Seven!
Key.
Mysterious key, it's so suspicious and weird.
It may make all your dreams come true.
This is the suspicious key.
You are so freaky and fun.
I can't wait to go to the black market with you.
I think I'm gonna die.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
It's over, Minky.
Ah!
Can I have your blessing to cosplay you and do parkour and break dancing?
Yes!
Be safe, though.
Hearing 10 minutes of Minto laughing will always be worth it.
though that asbestos never triggered not even what all the sweaty nubby players are like they're gripping their thighs like this stupid bee tuber wait 3d glasses ultra rare first peg popped a random peg emits a pulse that doubles pegs But then close range!
Woo!
But I have to freeze you.
I must freeze you.
Nose!
Ultra bear!
A random peg...
I can't get this one either though.
Sucks.
I want the nose.
Nobody hits the wall twice.
Doubles four random pegs whose number is less than 32.
Peg fully popped, pops the lowest number peg twice.
If I reroll, this still freezes, though, right?
Nah, you can only freeze one item.
I'm scared.
Oh, okay.
Happy seal.
Happy, happy, happy.
This might be...
Gives points equal to the number of times that Nubby has bounced this round.
How many times have it bounced?
Like, what's a hot... like...
What, I get like a hundred or something maybe?
Finger puppet can help you survive.
That's true.
Good early but bad later.
That's what I was thinking.
We can grab it for now and...
Just kind of Have it
Sneaky snipers Okay
Hmm, okay, that's not bad It's actually quite good Whoa, big, big Crazy Oh yeah, the eyeball The trainer I'm gonna get the spring For late game We are investing in our future Investing in the future
Hoppe Thank you, welcome back We got another rare Wait, I could get both If Nubby is still alive Someone an egg missile that falls from the sky continues an explosion that pops a row of pegs every half second wait that's crazy no
seems good it does seem good
it seems uh it seems not so bad
ah Gold Rush!
Come on.
Yeah, keep going.
Yeah!
So maybe, it probably would be good to not go for the high one, because then I could double it.
These eggs be crazy.
I'm going to try and get this guy again.
The key.
Rare.
Force triggered this item.
When this is force triggered.
I think we...
Maybe it would be good in five.
I can get it.
Nice.
E.
glasses goes crazy.
Oh, that's right.
I meant to not.
That's okay, though.
Oh, oh.
It, like, doesn't owe it.
Doubles pegs within a close range.
But it didn't hit the 500 one, which is why it's kind of interesting.
The eggs go crazy, for real.
What the heck?
Come on, get the thousand, get the thousand, get the thousand.
Nice!
We need cheese house.
We do.
Let me in.
What is that?
The pointer.
Peg fully popped.
Marks a random peg.
When a peg is marked, all pegs have the same number will be doubled.
If no pegs have the same number as the marked peg, a random peg will be doubled.
Wait a second.
I can't get any of these.
I just realized.
It doesn't let you buy slots here.
Oh no!
The alien.
Sell the E.
Oh, yeah, true.
We could sell the E.
Goodbye.
I guess I would...
We can always get it again.
I guess I could have sold the finger puppet, too.
I probably don't really need him.
I'm going to re-roll.
We got the flippy floppies.
We got the floppies.
All perks force trigger the item to the left of me.
Toy fish.
Two random pegs will copy the number of the first peg popped.
If the item in slot number seven...
If this item is in slot seven, four pegs will be affected instead of two.
Oh, interesting.
That would have been perfect for E, but we can get it back.
Yeah, we can get it back.
We can get it back.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, we lived.
Wizard.
What if I get this one and I put, like, 3D glasses or the...
Put the rocks on...
Yeah, these guys on glasses.
We could get this, and then I could put it all the way.
Okay.
Stratosphere time!
I want to see how far we can go.
Does it work like that?
I have no idea.
Maybe.
Uh oh.
Yikes.
Hey!
Nice indeed.
Wait, I could...
upgrade our finger puppet okay hold on first we gotta expand wait i kind of want to upgrade them double the number of the times that dubious bounces around
time to expand i'll expand again why not
springy this oh it uh slot five that's right five percent chance to force trigger item in slot five
I guess I guess we can have it trigger everything right re-roll let's try whoa what's this guy evil goose peg halved all pegs will give wait oh the peg has to be halved dang it all pegs will give points equal to double the number of the lowest number peg oh that's right it's corrupted it can't be forced you guys are right but I
can still do this because it forces oh wait, to the left just kidding, I don't know why I thought like all items to the left I'm stupid
asbestos but I have nothing that would have
glasses on five, corrupted on six well, I also got I have I had this, the force trigger, your leftmost item in your inventory.
That's why I have glasses on one.
Chicken on five?
Yeah, I feel like, you know, we could do that.
I think I'll just get this...
I don't want to just buy to buy, you know?
I kind of want to see what the bug does.
I want to see what the metamorphosizes.
Squirmy.
If I buy another slot, we could go to the cafe.
Oh, strawberry!
Ring.
Then I'm going to reroll.
Strawberry!
Ring.
coin okay i'm
gonna call it here
big number big number big number let's go
what is this doing it's fine
get it crazy holy cow that was crazy That was a bonkers Oh I didn't even hit it Money money money Oh 40% chance to force trigger the item in slot 3 When a peg is fully popped Nubby dies If you have passed the round goal this round Force triggers the item in slot 5 twice I got RW at a con Oh Thank you I thought you were ending the stream for a second.
Oh, sorry.
This did kind of...
As soon as I said it, I was like, wait, it kind of sounds like I'm ending the stream.
I was like, I'm going to call in here.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Slot 3.
I think the ray gun would be good.
Candle sounds good.
Oh, well, actually, no, wait.
But...
Oh, maybe we could, like, clear a map with Slot.
Okay.
I can't decide.
They're both pretty good.
Candle only fires if you pass anyway.
That's how I feel.
I would rather get something that can save me from death rather than like if we're certain of...
Certain of... I guess it would help us restock lives if we needed it.
I'm gonna get the ray gun though.
Dug.
holy cow the eggs go crazy what do we have here any strawberries strobe 50% chance to force trigger the rightmost item which would be him the rubber chicken rubber chickens gonna just gonna go
free coin Free coin?
Seal and asbestos.
I still haven't properly tried them, so...
Wait, can I... Yeah, I can't get both.
Let's try it.
How does the rubber chicken go?
The rubber chicken is like dropping all the eggs that are causing the explosions.
Every half second, like it's crazy good.
I'm gonna re-roll and see.
Cheese house!
We're at 30, so it will actually benefit us for right now.
Holy moly.
This game looks so peak.
It's so fun, actually.
Gosh, I'm like super into these types of games recently.
Oh my god, we got the almost...
Mega!
Super score!
Wow.
Asbestos.
Rogue Lakes are fun.
They are!
Oh!
Saved it to buy it later, right?
Stocks a random rare food item.
Whoa!
Avocado!
Gains 1% odds for rare items across all shops.
This does not increase odds of ultra-rare items.
Avocado good, is it?
I guess 1% is better than no percent.
what if i got this one too
it's risky i know i might not be able to afford it i might not be able to afford it
stack the rares well what if i get what if it's like 10 i can't afford it oh wait i would be able to afford if it's 10 let's eat it
I can't afford it!
10 pegs have has an x% chance to force trigger the item in slot 3 for each remaining life gain.
25% odds.
Sheesh.
They really want me to take the skull.
So
far though, we got a pretty good setup.
So far, though, our setup is not so bad.
We're pretty cozy right now.
We're pretty cozy.
Moap!
What does that do?
When pop for the first time, this peg will trigger a mega explosion that pops all pegs at once!
Moap!
Handle it!
I miss balloons.
Our setup is pretty cozy right now.
Oh my gosh, I want the kidney bean!
Bloons was sacrificed for Druids.
What happened to Bloons?
Nothing, I just haven't played it in a bit.
Sell Cheese House?
I think we can, honestly.
Oh wait, if I sold that, and then maybe I could...
Sell cheese for Jax.
Elmo, I'm trusting you.
Let's try it.
Let's try it, baby.
Let's sell cheese for Jax.
Sell this guy too.
Oh yeah, I think our finger puppet probably doesn't do so much either.
Like, I'm guessing, like, so he has...
He's been activated 46 times.
So what, he gives us 86 points?
Like, that's nothing for what we need, you know?
Oh.
I'm still in a dream.
Elmo.
With Jackson 3.
I just listened to you.
Oh no!
I'm gonna sell him.
I probably should have moved.
Hold on, never mind.
Eat the bean I would have How much?
16?
16 16 I would have 16 If I eat the bean The croissant The croissant was 17, oh?
Part of me wants to reroll and part of me wants to eat the bean.
Yeah.
Aquasio.
Yeah, it was 17.
I don't know if it's worth it.
I'm gonna reroll.
It's gonna hurt, but I'm gonna reroll.
Oh!
We could get free.
Do these stock?
The kebabs?
Yes.
They do.
Okay.
What could I put in the most?
What does it do?
50% chance to force trigger the rightmost item.
Every time a perk triggers, it also triggers glasses.
It is on death.
Yeah, that's why I'm, like, wondering.
I don't think it would be worth it for the asbestos.
But I don't know.
If Happy Seal would be...
either I think we have wait hold on no I don't think Jack's should be well it is 50% chance versus a 40% chance but this is also if it if Nubby dies so I think I'm gonna hold off for now we
could get it and then get something better later yeah I think we'll get it just so that we have the perk.
You know, it doesn't have to...
It doesn't have to always be, you know, immediate.
Okay.
All right.
Crazer!
What is this one?
Oh, yeah.
It's a...
What's the word?
Fragile.
Fragile little guy.
Oh, but this one's new.
House of Cardsburg.
15 pegs popped.
Force triggers all X popped items.
Do we have any X popped?
Would first popped count?
20 pegs popped.
Force triggers all items that summon anything, which we only have the espice dose.
No, dang.
This one, a seal would count, though.
So seal counts.
or asbestos oh and the egg missiles oh then we should get the egg we should get oh and the jacks oh my gosh okay eggy perk eggy perk we're on the moon baby
oh my god you guys we're we're numbing it
so this is how you play the game
Oh my god!
So this is how you play the game!
Oh my gosh!
Oh, free money?
She's nobody!
Oh, we got the same one.
Does this also stack?
So would it also be like...
Is it 50-50?
I mean, we have so much money right now.
I think it's fine.
More kebab.
The bean.
What do we get?
A lentil.
Randomizes all items in your inventory.
Oh.
Um.
That was not so good.
That was a random peg.
I'm going to reroll.
Tate.
100% chance to...
Oh my god.
We're going to get so many jacks and so many.
But it has to force trigger.
Never mind.
I
mean, I could always just grab something for now.
Could grab goose.
What's the goose here?
Pecks have.
All pecks will give points equal as ever the number to the closest number peg.
You got a rat reload.
Did I?
Yeah, let's do that.
But aren't I?
Rebow!
Oh, oh, oh, uh, uh, I don't know.
Hmm.
Let's just grab a goose, I suppose.
Tehranimou!
Welcome back!
Thank you!
More asbestos.
Asbestos for more drops?
I guess that's true.
Let's try.
We're trying, baby.
Oh my god.
Oh my
god.
This is so crazy.
Crazy!
Whoa!
Tornado perk!
Force triggers the leftmost item by two times?
Jumbling pegs increases x by plus two?
Okay.
The mystery one.
Oh no no no.
Okay.
This is why we love me though!
And it would do the glasses.
Okay.
Holy cow.
This is ridiculous.
It's ridiculous.
Um...
I'm going to the cafe.
I'm eating a mouse.
I'm going back.
I'm re-rolling.
This one, if we're clearing boards...
Oh, the asbestos!
That's right!
Asbestos.
And then I'm going to reroll.
And...
Eight, eight, eight, eight.
Not that I need more coins, but, you know.
I want to upgrade my jacks.
Yippee!
Where would I put the E though?
Wait, wait, hold on.
Force trigger this item.
When this is force trigger, it transfers the force trigger to the item to the left of me.
There's a 15% chance to add an additional force trigger.
Do the two fuse?
I don't think so.
No.
Jax to 7 for Euphoria?
jacks on the 40 the ray gun was for seven I
don't have anything for seven keep
triggering for ultra rare that's how I feel seven is right most wait what do I have for right most I have left most oh the kebab I guess we could switch them Both, right?
I mean, we have multiple espices.
No rare.
No ultra rare.
Okay.
Here they come.
You broke the game!
Oh my god!
Do you guys see my score?
Booker party!
Nubtastic.
I know she isn't...
This isn't gambling!
Oh my god.
gosh we get something next time though wait
is the memory gone are you feeling nub oh it's a gotcha
i'm gonna get all of it i'm gonna just we're just gonna empty the machine ten one empty the machine 10 2 We're learning how to count 10 8
Random I mean rare rare rare rare Rare rare rare rare Okay skip Skip Rare rare rare rare Skip.
Okay, we got the key at least.
Oh, take the key.
Don't skip.
All right.
Here it comes.
Oh my gosh.
What trillion?
I broke the game again?
This is actually kind of insane.
There we go.
Guys.
This is like, this is like to offset my Clover Pit luck, I feel.
Now you know how to do the ultimate.
built in Nubi's Number Factory.
This is a guide.
No!
No rare!
Lion would be proud.
You know, we always kill the game when the score starts using letters.
At least it's not E.
You can potentially upgrade your corrupted item and Three, re-roll.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's re-roll and see.
Oh, dang it.
I thought that was it for a second.
No!
Um.
I think fly is good, but I think I want to keep this one still.
Yeah, I have a good build.
Right now, it's very...
Right now, it's...
It's doing us good.
We're very comfy.
We're, like, cruising right now.
We're, like, actually just cruising.
What is this one?
This peg will subtract points instead of adding points when popped.
Oh, my gosh!
So many!
And it's...
Oh, okay, good.
Oh, no!
Oh, oh, oh, oh!
We made it!
Okay.
I was scared for a second.
Don't scare me like that!
It was so over for like two seconds.
Force triggers all Nubby.
What do I have?
I don't...
I was gonna say, I don't think I have any Nubby dies.
Springy Park!
Sun Temple.
Guys, we've made it to a new land!
Double springy, double springy.
Heg mania!
I don't even look at the score anymore.
I just wanted to know that you helped me through a very typical fun!
Keep being gringy and goofy and freaky.
Always looking forward to your streams.
Thank you!
Oh, there we go.
There it goes.
Guys.
I don't even, I don't even know.
We've broken the system.
Those pretty colors.
It's like we're watching fireworks together.
Oh!
Let's reroll.
Wait.
Yeah, let's try and get the 3D glasses.
Okay.
And the chicken.
Oh!
Lobster Clow.
Baby sensory video type gameplay.
Does the sound drown out the confession too?
Yeah, actually.
Yeah, I think 99 is the...
is the max number of coin.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna...
It hurts to re-roll because we have a rare, but...
And I'm going to re-roll here.
Huge, huge, huge.
50% chance to trigger the right most item!
Onwards.
The lobster claw isn't very good anyway.
It's funny because I watch the score go down because of the drainer perk, but it's funny that...
Like, it still works so well.
I mean, if you clear the board, you have to win, right?
Oh, a mystery is happening.
Don't touch me.
When popped for the first time, all other pegs will be doubled?
75% chance or halved.
Okay.
Spooky.
I don't know what happened.
Um, they were something.
Something happened.
Oh my gosh, we're at 1.4 billion.
Wait, the scores are actually probably going to get...
We really need to upgrade our stuff then.
Oh.
Because we're getting 50 billion right now.
but soon it's gonna get to that amount, you know what I mean?
Oh!
We can get the tornado perk again!
Wait, but...
We could also get... I think... Oh, geez.
I think...
I think the tornado...
It stacks, right?
So...
I keep forgetting to jumble the pegs.
We need more glasses, we do.
I'll start jumbling them just so I can remember.
ABJ always... No, no, no, no, ABJ!
No, no, no, no, no!
Huge.
Quasar!
We can finally afford it.
Just keep eating it, I guess.
Oh, wait, I'm gonna run out of coins, I just realized.
Oh, we did the Quasso do.
Has an X% chance to force trigger the item in slot number 3.
I could get the reroll.
We really need the glasses or the chicken.
Our rare odds are going up, though.
So that's good.
But we really need those.
Oh, I forgot to...
I forgot to jumble.
Seal on three and look for this.
I could try.
As long as I think having the...
Holy...
We got the Q!
What is it?
the queue when this peg this peg will multiply your total points why 1.5 times when popped for the first time okay okay quadrillion
how far can we get you guys how far do you think we can get in this Eventually, obviously, we would have to run out because if we can't upgrade our stuff anymore.
But the sound is starting to break even.
What is this guy?
Oh, poop butt.
Poop butt.
Oh, I should have probably...
Why did I do him first?
Oops, my bad.
Stocks are random ultra rare for...
Items!
Duplicates the most recently obtained perk.
The kebab perk.
There is a final level.
Oh.
Might as well, yeah.
What is this?
Mimics the effect of the most recently eaten...
Wait, so it'll summon an...
Wait, how much is this guy?
Oh, it's only six.
No!
Get away from me, Lentol!
Oh, we got the nose!
I'm thinking maybe...
The pebbles.
These?
The flippy flobbies?
Is that what you mean?
Flippy flobbies forces this to...
The glasses to...
It force triggers them.
But...
Only activated Y and say, ah, okay.
It only does it Y and say, ah.
I'm selling it.
We keep the flibby flobbies.
They're keeping us alive.
I don't think the flibby flobbies are the thing keeping us alive.
Keep flibby flobbies.
Maybe I don't quite understand.
This, though, the doubles, pegs is kind of helping us alive.
because the high we need we need the double pegs to go off like multiple times because that's how we're getting into the trillions yeah the doubling is exactly what like obviously we could clear a board but if the board it does not have a high enough of a score then it's then it's not gonna do anything
so that's why we need it i think i'm gonna re-roll i think we gotta I think we have to aim for chicken or for more glasses.
Something that will keep the scores going up.
Boards will have enough.
Try swapping seal and glasses.
I'll try it.
I'm going to reroll.
No, why can't you be chicken?
Chicken is just rare, right?
Yeah.
But we're starting to see more rare items, so...
But so far, we're okay, though.
So far.
Oh, my gosh.
So far, we're doing all right.
I love when we break the sound.
Not even.
Well...
Oh, that's right.
This one.
I like to go for the lowest so that this will...
so the glasses will trigger the double...
the double...
pegs.
So if you're wondering why I'm like aiming for lower ones.
because it'll make the other ones that are higher even higher
glasses i think glasses and one is was better i think you're right i'm gonna switch up oh dave 50 chance to double coins 50 chance to set total coins to zero i see How many 50% chances could we even get more for the kebab?
Dave, I'm not gonna pick you because I'm not gambling.
My coins, yeah, my coins are even maxed out, so it doesn't matter.
Stocks are random, much are rare, food item.
No, no, no.
You can jumble pegs plus one plus additional time.
per turn.
Oh, why not?
Plus one jumbo.
Okay.
Stop.
Get away from me.
Wait, we could re-roll here.
No, Dave.
No.
No, Dave, no.
Okay, this is how you And re-roll This is how you Oh my gosh, wait, this is crazy
More coins Then we re-roll here Whoa, Yeti Every peg will give Points equal to 15% of their Number
Hinako Wait, that's Actually, hold on.
Should we get rid of one of the asbestos for Yeti?
I'm excited to wear my minke cosplay!
Have you liked my minke board?
Yeah!
It was so cute!
Oh my gosh, Melody, thank you!
What triggers this?
First peg popped.
If asbestos doesn't count as pop, maybe swap it out for Super Jax.
It does not count.
Oh, I forgot that this gives 12 to 18% of the gold.
That's why we're, like, swimming in cash.
Yeah, asbestos is pretty good.
Whatever's doing least.
It feels like everything is doing a ton.
Because we need the pegs half, so we need the seal.
I mean
Jax is only when you pass the round goal I think Jax is getting a little tricky because we're reaching the we're gonna start reaching the round goal less less
but it also gets forced triggered oh that's true we have a uh
Force triggers all items that summon anything So it does summon I mean we do have that we do have that So never mind
Yeah, bypasses.
Yeah, and we do have the kebab also Which is a 50% chance to force trigger But everything already triggers It's already force triggers Phoebe, thank you for the redirect.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I won't get the Yeti then, but we will grab this.
And we will eat and we will re-roll glasses.
No, not.
Okay, let's just keep going then.
I
mean, we're still doing pretty dang good.
Piper bags, thank you so much for the gift.
Jacob, thank you for the gift.
Say, say, thank you for the gift.
I'm gifted.
Phil, thank you for the gift.
Whoa.
Tony!
Tony shoots lasers from his eyes.
If a peg is hit by a laser, its number will be reduced to one.
Where's Tony?
Oh, God.
Oh.
We're okay.
Oh, my gosh.
If anybody wants to see it, there you go.
If you're like, I want to play it.
I want to win.
I want to beat the game, too.
Aaron!
Thank you so much for the toani!
I think.
Wait, someone else.
Ahab, thank you so much for the 20 gifted!
Akia, stay up through.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Nawa, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you guys.
Sorry if I missed any.
Thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
Another game clear?
Does this count?
Another one for your goal.
This, I mean, I counted Peggle in my example, so maybe this counts too, right?
That's my whole shame.
We say, oh, nothing is...
This is number factory!
We are literally making numbers.
If Peggle can count, this can count.
I didn't expect to beat it.
Let's go!
Well guys.
I think though.
I don't think I'm gonna die any times.
I'm gonna get to the next...
Uh...
Re-roll.
None.
Go up to a hundred?
We can try- we can in for a hundred.
Seven coins!
Re-roll.
Whoa!
Uh, you re-roll?
Go away, Dave!
It ramps up pretty quickly.
I'm just kidding.
I want it to be an even 10.
I could take the risk.
But I'm not gambling because YouTube says it's wrong.
So did my mom.
Happy bladed Oshidemi, though.
Thank you, John.
Thank you.
We're board clearing, baby.
We're board clearing.
Oh yeah, let's start reshuffling and stuff too.
Let's try and get to 100 and then I'll call it.
Like we're getting to the T's.
It's mayhem.
Oh yeah.
Unless asbestos stops working in endless.
I don't think so.
What?
That's what I'm wondering.
We have, like, a most insane build?
Look at the things in the background.
There's, like, a, there was, like, a guy.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I got loot.
What?
Force triggers the item in slot 7.
One time for every 10 food items we've consumed.
Oh my gosh, 61 times.
No way.
Force triggers one random item.
Gourmet rules?
I mean, we've been getting like crazy stuff, so...
Okay.
see order of operations you first stocks yeah uh gourmet park stocks another one wait what oh the gourmet oh okay we doubled that okay um okay re-roll the lobster gosh we just can't get anything else
Eat, eat?
No!
Reroll?
Avocado?
Uh...
Will I be able to afford...
What is this?
Oh, the inflatable dolphin.
Coming in here with no context for this game has me questioning if this game is real.
Who is Dave?
Hi, Maple!
Kata, kata, kata, kata, kata, kata, kata, kata.
Oh my gosh, wait, Ducky, I missed your thing.
I'm going to be in Japan starting next week.
Any food or places you'd like me to feed?
Take you, Minky Plush.
Yes!
Yes, I know!
I want you to go to Taiyo no Tomato, man.
Taiyo, like sun, no.
Tomato, like tomato, men.
It is, oh my gosh.
It's basically ramen, but the...
But the base is tomato, like the soup, tomato soup.
It's so...
And I've been meaning to go the past couple of times.
But I keep having not...
Like, if I pass by one, I'm not hungry.
And if I am hungry, there's not one nearby.
It's so...
And they put cheese on it.
It's basically just spaghetti soup.
They put cheese on it.
And oh my gosh.
It's so stinking good.
Tomato men of the sun?
No, like noodles.
Men is noodles.
So, tomato men is my o susume, my recommendation.
Please take me there.
Please!
But put on the bib for me and for you so you don't get your clothes dirty.
Or me dirty.
Because that would be so, so sad if you got tomato on me.
Or you.
talking about while listening, so no idea what's happening in this game, but I like hearing happy meato noises.
I'm basically getting, I'm basically juggling, I'm basically juggling, and I'm getting huge Dave Potts, not Jack, no Jack, no Jack, I'm getting a Dave, Dave Potts instead.
We're juggling?
And we're getting huge Dave Pot.
But what did I else?
Oh, let's see if I can afford it.
Huge.
Okay.
Our rare odds are now 10%.
Actual TikTok speech.
I feel like!
I feel like I have to.
I'm being, my channel is being unalived right now.
I have to.
Thank you for explaining.
You're welcome.
Mega explosion.
Let's try it.
Oh, here we go.
When's it gonna clear the board?
Wait, I thought I was supposed to clear the board.
Yeah.
It's been gone by the lally-lo-lo!
We're in queue!
Oh, but the round!
Oh my gosh, it's now at T.
I broke the game again.
Wait, we're about to go to...
Um...
We're about to go back to the black market.
Oh my gosh, we're almost to round 100!
Vito acute!
So, play.
Three.
Silence, you two.
Bitrate blast.
Oh my gosh.
Nice.
Sorry.
Oh, we got a little excited.
Rare.
Pants.
Skip.
Rare.
Pants.
Skip.
Get pants, nerd.
10.
8.
I'll take it.
Ah, pants.
I'm so unbothered now.
Like, I'm just kind of like going the motion i feel like i've i've i've i've totally destroyed the game so much that it's it's like
insanity at this point you give you the real super secret ending by gaining so much score the game actually can crash wait really
I don't think I can lose because we're like actually scaling, you know?
So I don't know if we can lose.
Surprised you're still aiming?
Well, it's like I said, I, you know, I'm trying to aim for like the lower one so that I can get even bigger number.
But we have two left until 100.
This game can full on break.
Break break?
What if?
Reroll.
What is this?
Toy fish!
Two random pegs will copy the number of the first peg popped.
If this item is in slot 7, four pegs will be affected instead of two.
Oh.
You can crash it pretty easily with a crazy boot.
Sorry for the bitrate, everybody.
Okay.
Oh, not end game.
No, we're done.
Sorry, I almost clicked the wrong button.
That would have been so tragic.
This video has inspired me.
I'm going to remove all my home insulation and replace it with asbestos.
You can't lose, baby!
Asbestos party.
Boss round!
Holiday cheat rate!
How festive!
When popped, all pegs will copy this pegs as the...
number.
Holiday cheer.
It's time.
I don't want a lot for Christmas.
There's just the thing I need.
What's the gun do?
Buckshot.
Wait, can I not play Buckshot anymore either and
I what first
if this if the first peg popped was the highest number peg force triggers the item in slots one and two two times each guys
I'm gonna call it there I think I'm gonna call it there GG thank you everybody for Helping me create a god build in this game.
This was so fun.
This is so fun.
I had a lot of fun.
You can save, yeah.
Play with other builds.
Of course, go ahead.
But if you want the god build.
Obviously.
I thought we would.
Run out.
but nope.
Just kept on going.
It's all coming up Meantoo.
Baloney Tony has gone to...
I haven't even met that guy.
But yeah!
Thank you so much, everybody!
I hope you had fun.
And I will see you when I see you next!
You can unlock other characters with the stars.
Oh!
Well,
we beat the game!
Happy, I'm proud of us, I'm proud of us.
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time, zone, and I will see you when I see you.
Game number 35, clear!
Thank you, Reikni!
Otomito, everyone!
Eat at a shy!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Up, number, and I'm above.
The number, number.
More number is more number.
Always number, go up, number.
Number, number, I want number.
Higher number, bigger number.
I just want you to number.
More than number, more number.
What number can I do?
I want his number through the roof.